bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
fil 78 pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale voici les
principaux titres de ce lundi 30
septembre les magasins de bricolage
d'île de france doivent fermer c'est la
décision du tribunal de commerce de
bobigny qui a poussé hier le collectif
des bricoleurs du dimanche a une
nouvelle fois se faire entendre
pétitions manifestations pour défendre
leurs droits travail et nous serons en
ligne dans un instant avec une adhérente
yvelinoise de ce collectif les
professionnels se penche sur les risques
liés à la consommation de cannabis mme
centre charcot de plaisir ou encore
l'institut de promotion de la santé
partenaires pour mieux comprendre les
usages actuels et les solutions de
prévention vie locale et l'automne qui
est bel et bien là les exposants et les
visiteurs de la brocante d'elancourt
l'ont constaté dimanche la pluie est
venue gâcher la fête nous sommes passés
entre les gouttes à la rencontre était
plus courage on commence par l'image de
ceux à lundi l'image du jour la société
de production adrénaline qui s'est
installée à montigny le bretonneux pour
le tournage de ligne de mire un téléfilm
réalisé par nicolas herdt pour france 2
est l'histoire d'une famille frappée par
la crise et qui découvre une mallette
d'argent qu'un tueur à gages va tout
faire pour récupérer liane foly ou
encore lola dewaere la fille de patrick
dewaere font partie de ce casting le
tournage va se prolonger dans le reste
de la france jusqu'à la mi octobre pour
une diffusion l'an prochain le collectif
des bricoleurs du dimanche en colère
contre la décision du tribunal de
bobigny d'obliger la fermeture le
dimanche des enseignes castorama et
leroy merlin en ile de france plus
précisément 15 magasins à rueil frêne ou
encore ivry-sur-seine n'y pas d'enseigné
yvelinoise concernés à ce jour en ligne
avec nous au 110 lopin bonsoir
vous êtes membre du collectif salariés
d'une des enseignes de bricolage à bois
d'arcy ce matin il ya une réunion à
matignon pour évoquer ce dossier un
dossier un rapport va être rendue dans
les prochains mois sur cette question
quel est votre sentiment le collectif
n'est pas satisfait de ce nouveau
rapport qui a été commandé par matignon
il me semble non toute affaire n'est
appelée vraiment déçu parce qu'en fait
je suis un rapport supplémentaire on
n'arrête pas ça fait un an qu'on parle
du sujet du dimanche façon qu'on en
avait déjà parlé les années précédentes
là on nous manque quelque chose comme si
c'était un sujet qui venait de tomber
aujourd'hui sur la table
mouchon demande c'est d'avoir un décret
qui permettrait de rester harding et
convenablement aujourd'hui et c'est
urgent mais crime affirmant aux amendes
à payer on a besoin absolument de ce
décret pour pouvoir travailler en toute
sérénité puisqu'on n'est pas mon cas ah
oui quitte à être hors la loi puisque
matignon a aussi rappelé à ce matin
qu'en attendant ce nouveau rapport et
d'éventuelles nouvelles décisions les
magasins qui devait fermer le dimanche
devront être fermés c'est une sanction
de 120000 euros environ par magasin à
chaque fois qu'une infraction est
constatée ces magasins doivent ouvrir ou
fermer actuellement dimanche prochain
ils seront ouverts
par des autorisations
pour une quinzaine de ses magasins de la
région parisienne il a été demandé qu'il
soit fermé le dimanche et ça ne concerne
pas les yvelines oui et donc là même les
autorisations et qu'ils n'ont pas à
fermer ils ont des autorisations
de plus le droit exactement
aujourd'hui les magasins évinois jeunes
ne sont pas concernés ni par les
nouvelles décisions qui sont tombées
récemment
pour autant est-ce que vous vous sentez
menacés vous sur bois d'arcy par exemple
alors à mon sens pas directement menacée
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
cependant si la mère
ne s'arrête pas là est-ce que là pour
l'instant effectivement fait l'écho rama
qui a attaqué des magasins et paraissait
être dans chaque zone de concurrence
cependant si l'électorat mal fermée
c'est principalement
et donc il ya un rapport de défiance
entre les syndicats les salariés aussi
que vous représentez un petit peu au
sein du collège
vous même vous travailler le dimanche
alors qu'elle manque à gagner ça
représenterait kouassi le travail le
dimanche devaient être interdits sur
l'enseigne dans l'ensemble de ses
enseignes à travers la france oh moi ça
peu près 150 euros argument ce que je
gagne sachant que on a un chiffre
d'affaires aussi
plus importante dimanche c'est que ça
permet d'obtenir de meilleurs prix de
meilleure participation donc c'est pas
évident d'évoluer comme ça la perte
exacte que c'est vrai mais serait une
très grosse cote de 2,10 à peu près de
trois dimanches par mois et quand tu
sais ça metering l'intéressement a
baissé et qu'à l'heure actuelle un
critique
je suis très
ouvertement donc qui a demandé la remise
d'un nouveau rapport sur cette question
de l'ouverture le dimanche en attendant
pas de nouvelles décisions les
politiques qui sont assez partagés
finalement sur cette question peut citer
aussi benoît hamon ministre de la
consommation ou de l'économie solidaire
qui est défavorable à l'ouverture le
dimanche vous avez malgré tout le
sentiment de trouver de trouver des
personnes au gouvernement qui vous
entendre qu'ils vous soutiennent dans
quel état d'esprit vous êtes par rapport
à ça
nous avons
nous avons une lettre ouverte au complet
d'études député qui a été mise en ligne
début mai et
c'est un contrat pour vous c'est
contradictoire merci sans développe un
salarié donc d'une enseigne de bricolage
à bois d'arcy et le collectif à des
bricoleurs du dimanche qui reste donc un
mobilisés après les décisions de
matignon de remettre un nouveau rapport
sur cette question avant de prendre une
nouvelle décision merci à vous
autre dossier qui fait polémique c'est
la réforme des rythmes scolaires plus de
13 mille signatures pour une pétition
lancée par le maire d'elancourt l'ump
jean michel fourgous soutenu par jean
françois copé une pétition pour le
report de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires dénoncé comme néfaste pour les
enfants et entraînant une forte hausse
d'impôts pour les familles réforme est
présentée comme pratiquement
inapplicable dans cette pétition nous y
reviendrons dans notre journal de demain
et vous entendrez l'excellent
explications du maire d'elancourt qui a
lancé cette pétition en ligne sur le
site national de cette formation
d'opposition l'ump politique toujours
avec la dernière séance du conseil
général des yvelines en date c'était
vendredi particulièrement attendue
puisqu'elle signait le retour en
politique de l'ancien président de ce
conseil général pierre bédier un
conseiller général a paru très
silencieux pendant tout cela c'est en ce
retour sur cette matinée avec catherine
de la tohu olivier maniscalco
première séance de rentrée au conseil
général des yvelines et beaucoup de
monde en coulisse certainement
impatients et curieux de revoir parce
qu'il est l'ancien président du conseil
général pierre bédier pendant toute la
séance le conseiller général de man tu
n'as pas pris part aux débats assez
concentré mais très silencieux tout
juste at il souri quand le président
alain schmitt en parlant de l'importance
des enjeux de paris métropole a salué
son retour par ces mots
on se souvient qu'il ya quelques mois on
murmurait dans les allées du conseil
général que pierre bédier aurait bien
aimé retrouver le fauteuil de président
fauteuil qu'il a occupé de 2005 à 2009
on a besoin d'aller d'alain schmitz
aussi donc ça veut dire qu alain schmitz
est mon ami donc après ne partait pas
sur des considérations politiques ça
vous obsède cette présence du conseil
général ça vous obsède beaucoup plus que
moi moi je veux servir peu importe mais
peu importe les postes peu importe les
postes de l'important c'est de servir
l'important c'est d'avoir des idées et
l'important c'est d'avoir la capacité de
mettre en oeuvre ses idées pour
justement servir les populations voient
la touchante en mes collègues de la
majorité dire on a besoin de pierre
bédier contenu de ces grandes
difficultés que connaît le département
on a vu ce matin qu'en fait tout ça est
très artificielle le département
continue et doit continuer c'est un non
événement
ça fait beaucoup de vagues à l'intérieur
de la majorité départementale pour moi
personnellement c'est un non événement
car bédié avait dû abandonner son
fauteuil de conseiller général après
avoir été condamné en 2009 à trois ans
de privation de droits civiques pour
corruption passive et recel d'abus de
biens sociaux dans les rangs de la
majorité on ne tarit pas d'éloges sur
lui expérience compétence dynamisme
fougue
change politique très développé je crois
que le retour de pierre bédier pour le
conseil général c'est une très bonne
chose bien bédié va intégrer la
commission permanente et la deuxième
commission équipement
on va parler d'une thématique santé à
présent de la consommation du cannabis
avec en plateau le docteur federico car
horace bonsoir à vous êtes 6-4
addictologue au centre hospitalier jean
martin charcot à plaisir docteur marling
benoit marchessault bonsoir à vous
directrice de l'institut de promotion de
la santé daniel vialla bonsoir à vous
vous êtes en charge des questions de
santé pour la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
aujourd'hui s'est déroulée à trappes une
journée de sensibilisation sur ces
risques liées au cannabis pour les
adolescents pour commencer on va
regarder ce reportage de yolaine thorez
et de jonathan vilma nil étaient
présents ce matin et ensuite nous
discuterons autour de cette table
la france championne d'europe de
consommation de cannabis chez les jeunes
les médecins et associations présents ce
lundi ont insisté sur ce point la moitié
des jeunes de 17 ans l'aurait déjà
expérimenté lorsqu'il est consommé avec
l'alcool les risques se multiplient la
prise de cannabis
lorsqu'il ya de l'alcool associés va
augmenter cette prise alcool puisque le
cannabis donne soif et donc on va encore
plus consommé de l'alcool par ailleurs
le cannabis induit des problèmes de
jugement donc on va être incapable de se
rendre compte un petit peu de ce qu'on
fait et donc il va y avoir un effet
boule de neige entre le cannabis et
l'alcool et donc de multiplication des
risques et des signes d'ivresse
phénomène de groupe simple amusement le
cannabis est séduit surtout les
adolescents des adolescents parfois
lassés des discours moralisateurs sur la
consommation pour jean paul manaranche
il faut promouvoir d'autres pratiques de
sensibilisation travail sur l'estimé de
soi à travers sur les affirmations sur
l'esprit critique prier uniquement
travailler sur ces produits pour un
servant de ventre je vous dis ils
peuvent plus de l'entendre c'est
tellement ils ont employé mais
aucun médicament ne permet pour
l'instant de lutter contre la dépendance
le meilleur conseil des médecins dans ce
cas là c'est de ne pas rester seul c'est
surtout de se faire accompagner dans des
structures pluridisciplinaires où il ya
des médecins et des psychologues pour
pouvoir prendre en charge le patient
dans sa globalité et l'aider mais il
n'existe pas de médicament et pas de
substituts oth est
ciblé verser sevrage le cannabis est
toujours illégal en france toute
personne qui on possède risque un an
d'emprisonnement et 3750 euros d'amendé
nous allons donc parler de cette
question du cannabis durant les
prochaines minutes avec des médecins en
plateau mais aussi une représentante des
élus vous êtes élu à la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
charge des questions de santé on va
commencer avec vous est ce que c'est un
enjeu sanitaire sociétale cette question
du cannabis aujourd'hui bien sûr et j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de venir plusieurs
fois sur ce plateau pour expliquer la
position aussi de la communauté
d'agglomération en matière de santé
marine m'a vraiment marchessault qui est
là et la directrice de l'institut de
promotion de la santé c'est bien une
volonté politique aussi d'avoir mis en
place cette structure est l'objectif
c'est évidemment de promouvoir la santé
et de promouvoir la prévention en santé
dans les politiques se saisissent de ce
dossier ce qui a lieu la pose la
question aux médecins de s'inquiéter
véritablement de la consommation de
cannabis des adolescents aujourd'hui oui
bien sûr et
certes on ne voit pas tout de suite
quels sont les complications mais nous
on de point de vue clinique quand c'est
que ça peut déclencher de certaines
pathologies et que ça va peut mener un
échec scolaire 20h et que socio
économique d'une personne il faut
s'inquiéter l'inquiétude porte aussi sur
la concentration alors c'est plus
technique de th et c'est cette molécule
toxique on retrouve à l'intérieur du
cannabis de plus en plus forte cette dh
et oui le thc tétrahydrocannabinol c'est
les composants actifs
du cannabis vous avez vous saviez en
scène et 68 une consommation de une
plante qui avait 5 6 % de thc
aujourd'hui on peut trouver dans le
commerce jusqu'au 30 35% de
concentration c'est qu'il n'y a ni cause
une absorption plus intense au décès
fait qu'ils sont un peu plus important
et surtout que ça reste dans le cerveau
plus longtemps avec des risques de
développer des symptômes psychotiques
des symptômes à motivationnelle avec un
et la menthe des mots le manque de
motivation pour avoir les activités et
comme j'ai dit c'est à l'heure l'échec
scolaire implique un aujourd'hui lé ps
par exemple vous recevez beaucoup de
jeunes qui s'inquiète qui aujourd'hui
sont dépendants et qui se disent je
n'arrive plus à décrocher du cannabis
parce que faut aussi les faire venir
mais une fois qu'ils ont conscience du
problème alors en fait il ya plusieurs
services au niveau de libé est ce qu'ils
peuvent recevoir des jeunes en
difficulté donc il ya d'abord le lieu
écoute jeunes mais il ya aussi le sa
part avec une une consultation de jeunes
usagers il y à d'autres professionnels
aussi d'autres associations et
professionnels dans dans le qui sont
hébergés donc au niveau de libé est ce
qu'ils peuvent également participer à
cette a7 prévention mais oui oui on rend
riad et des jeunes qui viennent avec
s'être lui matic là y'a des parents
aussi qui viennent en ayant des craintes
pour pour leurs enfants quels conseils
vous donnez aussi aux parents par
exemple nous voir alors s'ils viennent
pas me voir moi comme je viens de dire
ils viennent voir donc les autres
professionnels qui sont installés au
niveau de deux lits ps et puis ils vont
voir d'autres professionnels comme
monsieur que je nage
quels conseils il ordonné à ces familles
justement vous quand vous les recevez
c'était une question qui était
développée en janvier d'un agent tenait
donc
et c'est difficile de dire
une réponse unanime mais il faut voir un
château de cartes par cas qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour chaque adolescent
surtout une des conclusions ça il faut
pas banaliser il faut se poser la
question pourquoi dans ce contexte
particulier il ya cette consommation et
comment on
expliqué à la famille qu'elles sont les
possibles conséquences pour la voir
surtout un rôle préventif faut-il agir
contre le cannabis avez vous conscience
de ces dangers nous sommes allez vous
poser la question vaut réponse avec ce
micro trottoir de matrix jacques de
dixmude je crois que c'est pas une
priorité de lutter contre le cannabis
c'est plutôt entre guillemets comme ont
légalisé les choses en toute conformité
on sait que médicalement parlant ça
apporte beaucoup de bien aux gens qui
sont conservés il faut lutter contre à
l'utilisation du cannabis pour les pour
les ados
pour les ados donc je pense que c'est
surtout aux parents d'être vigilants
déjà plus de restriction sur l'alcool
mais le cannabis soit plus encadré mais
que le cannabis pas les accueille le
palais tout ce qui est drôle dur moi je
suis pour la libéralisation du de ce
produit sacré trop de moments dirait ce
sacré trop de violence à moi je pense
que oui parce que le cannabis est
mauvais pour les jeunes peut-être que
pour des adultes c'est bon mais enfin
c'est bon c'est neutre mais pour les
jeunes
je pense qu'il faut les protéger
voilà faites ce que je dis pas ce que je
fais ça c'est pour les adultes ça
concerne tout le monde dans le cannabis
sur les adultes oui c'est pas étonnant
les réponses qui a parlé de
l'égalisation aux et oui en fait
statistiquement parlant la consommation
est très important de français on a vu
ce matin comment la france les pays les
plus consommateurs en europe au niveau
de cannabis
presque un an un garçon de moins de 17
ans sur deux a déjà goûté le cannabis
donc on a tendance à banaliser cette
consommation mais nous devons vue
clinique
quand on voit que 'ses et
soixante dix pour cent des patients
schizophrènes consomment du cannabis on
sait que c'est un facteur prédisposant à
la maladie
quand on voit que les jeunes n'arrivent
pas à reprendre un cours qui sont en
retard qui il ya cet absentéisme on sait
qu'il ya des complications c'est pas que
les jeunes qui ont des soucis on a des
adultes assez souvent cette consommation
de cannabis évolué d'un étang et à
famenne d'autres addictions avec un si
on prend de la de cannabis que des
scènes de torkham tout à l'heure il ya
aussi une implantation de la soif et on
va se mettre à consommer de l'alcool
reparler des garçons tout à l'heure qui
secoue le groupe sans que la saisie
concerne tous les garçons que les filles
oui sur ces questions là sur la question
de la légalisation je posais la question
pour faire un tour de table pour contre
quand en ce qui concerne les pouvoirs
publics les élus aussi composition vous
défendez contre également
personnellement
et quand on entend parler tout de même
de violences qui en découlent c'était ce
qu'il ressortait du livre au trottoir
vous alerte pas ça entraîne des trafics
santraine des violences peut-être dans
certains pays forcément c'est assez
légaliser prochainement peut-être aux
etats-unis aussi puisque ça a été la fin
de la prohibition était approuvée dans
les états du colorado et washington
voilà bientôt en uruguay également les
autres pays qui légalise le cannabis il
faut le prendre mais il faut avoir la
nuance et il ya des pays où le cannabis
et alizée comme médicament vous avez le
canada par exemple où c'est un
médicament avec un cadre spécifique vous
avez la californie ou aussi un
médicament après si jamais on légalise
il ya des pays où il ya une dose
maximale une dose personnel qui ne peut
pas dépasser c'est pas autorisé le
trafic est évident qu'il faut se poser
la question et quand on parle de
l'égalisation c'est un contexte socio
économique majeur avec la violence avec
le trafic des stupéfiants c'est la
deuxième source d'argent après les armes
dans le monde c'est énorme c'est cher ça
coûte des vies le mois un temps
originaire d'un pays producteur de
cocaïne en colombie je sais de quoi je
parle et ne peut pas être pour la
légalisation c'est très grave
quand on voit les soucis personnels des
patients aujourd'hui journée à
l'information qui s'est déroulé pour les
professionnels pour les parents d'élèves
également quel message à retenir pour
eux pour ceux qui étaient présents
aujourd'hui vous leur diriez quoi il
faut s'inquiéter à partir de quel moment
comment réagir il faut toujours
s'inquiéter il ne pas banaliser ce qu'il
faut favoriser une fois la prévention il
faut l'éducation et c'est pas quand on
découvre qu'elle garçon et la fille de
15 ans et a recommencé à consommer il
faut s'inquiéter c'est beaucoup plus tôt
il faut qu'on sache quelles sont les
conséquences il faut quand même forme et
qui on sache qu'il y à un réseau qui est
prêt à accueillir les demandes procès et
les adresses de vos centres médicaux
hospitaliers qui sont affichées à
l'écran pendant qu'une discussion merci
à tous les trois est revenu donc sur ce
plateau aussi rester dans la
problématique de la santé à présent avec
le samsah le service d'accompagnement
médico-social pour adultes handicapés il
existe depuis 2008 à voisins le
bretonneux il vient de s'implanter à
plaisir le reportage les précisions de
yolaine 13
nathalie est un peu stressé dans
quelques minutes elle devra faire un
discours pour l'inauguration des
nouveaux locaux du samsah mercredi
dernier on l'a préparé avec les averses
à un certain jésus 14
j'ai oublié ma nage qui je vais être
obligée là dans ma taille avec fois je
n'ai même pas je n'aime pas travailler
dessus je suis franchement que j'ai même
pas travailler
nathalie fait partie des vingt adultes
handicapés qui bénéficient du samsah
tous les mardis elle reçoit un éducateur
à son domicile pour l'aider dans les
tâches quotidiennes notamment pour les
courses c'est un soutien et surtout pour
penser pour les courses mac a pas le
droit de porter
pour moi le cancer jeudi l'ancien homme
pour moi ça me fait une charge en moins
ici avec son assistante sociale elle
demande de l'aide pour quelques
démarches administratives
le service a pour vocation d'aider les
personnes en situation de handicap à
être maintenus à leur domicile
médecins éducateurs spécialisés ou
encore infirmières apporte soutien et
suivi dans différentes démarches on
compte 200 m ca au sein des yvelines
dont celui ci qui vient de se
délocaliser à plaisir il propose en
accompagnement différent on peut rester
chez soi être handicapé et bénéficier
dans l'accompagnement multidisciplinaire
voilà aller faire ses courses aller au
cinéma accéder à la vie socioculturelle
aller au travail et continuer à rester
chez soi avec sa famille ses enfants
voilà pour certaines personnes
c'est l'heure du discours devant
l'assemblée et le maire de plaisir à
nathalie reste très concentré quel 2
révèle réellement aux alevins et ont
pour rôle de m'accompagner dans mes
projets cela leur convient
véhicules mobilier matériel informatique
et bureautique appartenant à la mairie
de versailles sont en vente sur le site
tagora store point fr depuis quatre ans
la ville entend donner une seconde vie
aux matériels dont elle se sépare par
des enchères publiques vous pourrez
ainsi acquérir un photocopieur à partir
d'une centaine d'euros ou encore une
peugeot 106 électrique à partir elle de
300 euros mais sans batterie et avec
plusieurs pièces à changer tout de même
la vente se termine le 14 octobre
toujours sur internet un nouveau site
pour la paroisse catholique de montigny
voisin après la création d'un nouveau
logo la paroisse continuer à moderniser
son identité visuelle et entend ainsi
séduire un public habitué aux nouvelles
technologies vous y trouverez des
informations concernant la vie de la
communauté ainsi que plusieurs services
en ligne ce week end avait lieu la 31e
édition de la fête de l'automne à
elancourt une brocante qui accueille
chineurs et curieux l'occasion de faire
des emplettes sans se ruiner et malgré
la pluie du week-end de reportages
olivier maniscalco et anthony rech
ce dimanche ce 31e fête de l'automne
elle en cours avec sa traditionnelle
brocante claudine est venu avec ses
ficelles mike amis à l'occasion de faire
plaisir à tout le monde sans se ruiner
il était grande des plus grandes
affaires mais ça se trouvera ici avec
les chaussures ou des bottes et des
chaussures à talons des chaussures de
soirée un peu de tout et tout ça pour
5,6 euros
claire elle tient un stand de chaque
année depuis 10 ans sur place depuis
6h30 elle est venue vendre des livres
des vêtements et de la vaisselle c'est
des choses dont on se sert plus où on a
plus envie de voir et on se dit que ça
peut faire le bonheur de quelqu'un
d'autre donc si ça nous a servi ça peut
servir à quelqu'un d'autre aussi négocié
c'est but du jeu aussi la négociation
propose un prix la personne n'est
d'accord le jeu s'arrête mais après il
ya la négociation qui peut être très
intéressante aussi et ça permet de
discuter avec les gens si vous avez raté
la fête de l'automne ce week-end pas
d'inquiétude les communes de rambouillet
maurepas et magny les hameaux organisent
leur vide greniers les 5 et 6 octobre
prochain alors amis chineurs soyez au
rendez vous
un mode de sport pour terminer ce
journal il est désormais l'homme le plus
rapide d'europe sur le kilomètre il y a
quelques semaines le représentant de
vélizy andy jarrier est devenu champion
d'europe anthony rech pour le reportage
depuis deux saisons où il vit une
seconde carrière exceptionnelle après
avoir arrêté le vélo pendant huit ans il
ya dujarrier devenu au pays de galles
l'homme le plus rapide d'europe sur le
kilomètre
pourtant le champion de france court
dans l'anonymat malgré une saison 2013
au plus que parfait et le sentiment
d'avoir d'avoir réalisé l'objectif qui
était fixé dès le départ
alors un titre non ça ne dépense jamais
de soi ça dépend un petit peu de toutes
les circonstances de course mais il faut
être prêt le jour j grosse satisfaction
personnelle et et encouragements pour la
suite aussi parce que ça donne envie de
continuer à prendre s'est enlevée
lysiens rêve encore de décrocher le
titre mondial
le seul qui manque à son palmarès mais
en attendant l'ouverture du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce chef de
cuisine en reconversion s'entraînant
mode système d au milieu des voitures il
enchaîne les kilomètres d'effort une
fois par semaine il doit même se rendre
à chartres ou à roubaix pour caresser la
piste j'habite à vingt minutes du
vélodrome
ce sera un travail formidable maintenant
on attend de savoir quels créneaux
horaires nous pourrons avoir parce que
ben les créneaux sont réservés d'abord
pour l'équipe de france
ce qui est sûr c'est que je ferai partie
des premiers abonnés ça quel que soit le
tarif y'a pas de problème koffi comme le
surnomme le peloton n'est pas seulement
bon sur la piste il est passé sur lui
roues depuis une dizaine d'années
lorsqu'il arrête le vélo la première
fois et le roller lui permet de
progresser sur la scène j'ai besoin du
vélo pour progresser en roller parce que
j'ai une des grosses est une technique
donc le vélo m'aide à progresser
physiquement maintenant le roller quand
je travaille de sprint en rollers med en
explosivité pour lever le champion de
france de sprint en 2012 yann dujarrier
s'alignera début octobre sur les
championnats nationaux de marathon pour
un nouveau titre juste par passion et le
point complet sur le sport c'est avec
anthony rech 18h30 chaque lundi le sept
huit sports je vous retrouve demain
mardi pour une nouvelle édition de
l'actu et puis également pour une
nouvelle édition de municipales 2014
pour tout savoir du scrutin de mars
prochain excellente soirée